i'm going to save that i'm going to save
that
because it's off topic from opi i want
to go from opi to stuttering jobs he
brought the stuttering john [ __ ] now
this is going to be one of the more
vicious rants i think i've ever heard
him go on
and then we got another
stuttering job related okay and i'm not
even by the way shout out to dabblers
anonymous
on youtube if you guys want to follow
dabbler's anonymous on youtube
i've been getting some primo clips from
this uh channel
uh narmosh thrash what did john do well
john started telling everybody to donate
to his paypal and that all the money
that goes to his paypal
would go to this guy that's this
anonymous person that had cancer
cancer
beloved chatter
with
cancer
and everybody kind of smelled [ __ ]
everybody went um
something's not right with this
and uh turns out that many people are of
the opinion of what john's doing is
[ __ ] illegal
i have to say it that way so i don't get
sued
i'm sorry jimmy thank you a beloved
chatter's loved one
that he needed an ipad that i got for
him
i got it full room
so
anthony's was the first guy to really
come out anthony and carl were the first
people to come out and go this is a
[ __ ] scam right i think even aunt
i think anthony beat carl to the punch
because carl does his show i think once
a week right or twice a week or
something like carl doesn't do daily
show so this was one of those ant got on
first
and ant was like this is [ __ ] wildly
illegal you're a scam artist john
whatever it's now john's of course as
you guys know from last week's clips
he's like i'm suing
a certain uh
pockmarked criminal
is about to get surfed
so he's been threatening to sue ant
and uh well this was ant's reaction
being subtle here
yes
update and i'm not even being subtle
here
yes yes based on everything i know about
stuttering john personally
having known stuttering john over the
course of the years
having seen the way he acts with people
having seen what he said to
people the blatant lies that i've seen
him tell
based on that
i will absolutely say that i believe he
has been stealing money
under the guise of uh curing cancer
there get your lawyer john
now
now listen
this is what we call a pro gamer move
now
i have certainly at times
as you've seen we kicked off the year
this year
remember just eight months ago we kicked
off this year with me
sticking it a couple knuckles deep into
some lawyer guy from vegas
and royce and i have
also had some public
things that were legal that we were able
to kind of stare down large companies
and lawyers and stuff and just tell them
to go [ __ ] themselves
but even when you do that right you
generally like will find funny clever
little ways to like still keep saying
the thing but without it being
slanderous or anything
very rarely have i or royce ever pulled
this move out this move right now is a
pro move
to
to just go i am making
i am making a legally actionable
statement that yes you are stealing this
money
holy [ __ ] dude
that's
that's beyond like
because like the reason i've done that
before we go on and go all right they
told us to say that they absolutely
unequivocally do not steal money
and then just say somebody doesn't steal
money so many times that it's obviously
a bit and you're making fun of them
there's so many little ways you can go
around it but the way ants just like i'm
saying unequivocally
that you're stealing this money
i don't even like it but i respect the
move
get your lawyer for another
non-lawsuit sue me
sue me i won't show up in court i won't
answer it i won't pay you
i won't do it i'll move to south
carolina you can try to chase me down
there whatever you want to do you
blithering fool
go ahead
this lawyer must be do you have pictures
of him blowing men
i wouldn't take your call
i wouldn't take your call
if i was a lawyer a baker a [ __ ]
it doesn't matter tinker taylor soldier
spy it's john [ __ ] this idiot i'm not
picking up the phone i don't know how
you get this guy on the phone again i
think that's a lie too so he uh he's
been
uh talking about this uh
this chemo thing and this is so
hilarious uh a chatter has a loved one
that needs chemotherapy for cancer john
told them i'll do something and they go
hey please keep it on the qt i don't
want uh
people to know who we are and john go
sure i'll do that
so send it to my account so
he he gets upset if anyone even believes
that he might
be uh
misappropriating some of these funds uh
but he can't figure out why
because you're an [ __ ] you've been an
[ __ ] your whole life
and of course you'd do anything to get
more money you blew through every penny
you made uh you didn't make much on
howard stern we know you were making
something in the realm of between 30 and
35 000 a year
free and you stayed there forever
you finally left but you stayed there
making [ __ ] money for what
fame was more important than that
stuttering john
right before i went on the air uh
tweeted
he tweeted
trying to uh he took a picture that i
had which i put a little little comic
strip bubble of his daughter and him and
justin fleming comedies this is this
is this the aew post fight presser yeah
this is the media scrum
a picture and i said uh i don't know
something about his love and i gotta
mutilate myself oh jesus and john got
very angry at that
very angry
and uh all right this is the one thing i
this
this is the one thing i really don't
like
um
but i also know aunt has always been
somebody that
will absolutely go for your jugular if
you're uh
if you're [ __ ] with him
uh but i don't know i get uncomfortable
with the i just don't like i don't like
the stuff with people's kids and i'm not
saying
john's
son
is a kid
it's an adult you know what i mean but
when i say don't involve people's kids
or wives i mean don't involve their even
their adult children like i just don't
there's so much weird internet stalking
[ __ ] that happens
and um
i don't know what d with these fans
nowadays and these
weird gay ops and he's like you know try
hards out there that like i don't know i
just don't like to get the
i like to leave the kids in the you know
what i mean i look i don't know why his
daughter son sorry
ended up the way they did i don't know
of course he included twitter support
and okay
this is though as much as aunt going
after his kid is kind of [ __ ] up
john just always finds a way to be worse
he was trying to get anthony canceled
again glad bullies out rain and twitter
support this person is bullying and
harassing me and my transgender
childhood social media
his name is anthony kumia
criminal and poc
this is one of his tweets where he is
engaging in this despicable hateful
behavior
you're defecable
i hear it's rabbit season
duck season
despicable
uh so he he he knew he knew this was
coming
a lot of people i think knew today i was
gonna go on
and just lambast this [ __ ]
[ __ ] for what he is
and the worst part for john is
where are you going where are you going
wait
you're going to call iraq
are you going to get iraq
to tell me to be quiet
you could call maybe maybe garrett and
drew you could offer them some money and
they'll just hit the off switch
and that'll be it
where are you going john don't give a
[ __ ] anymore
that we've already been backed into a
corner
and and built up something that that we
needed to have to continue
speaking our minds and calling out
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] like you
do you understand
oh what twitter twitter support what are
they're gonna cancel my account
oh well i just made it to 10 000
followers i assumed i'm getting canceled
soon that's usually the schedule
there'll be another boss
slowly we'll get up to the email and
i'll still talk to people whatever it is
so who the [ __ ] are you calling john
your lawyer
you're gonna sue me like i said sue away
[ __ ] come up serve me with papers
first see me in a courtroom i will not
entertain
your your lawsuit
i won't pay you
you could try to [ __ ] get more
lawyers to try to pay me whatever you
need to do
but john you you what are you doing how
do you think you're stopping me
his little attempt at scaring me
on on social media today because he knew
i was going to talk about him
and his [ __ ] uh uh his poor i feel
bad for his family i feel bad
i feel bad
you are such a piece of [ __ ]
if you really had any [ __ ]
morality
or empathy or sympathy or any pathy
wanting to help someone
here's what you would have done
out of your own money that you profess
to have plenty of
you would have sent them
a donation
never mentioning it on your show
never even mentioning it
hey what happened ah my [ __ ] dude my
wife or hey my husband whatever it is
as chemo uh is getting chemo it's so
expensive we don't have insurance
whatever oh dude that sucks
all right you got a venmo
no dude you don't have to [ __ ] you give
me the venmo i just want to help
and then you send it over and then you
go on and do your show and you never
mention it that's what a person
that cares about people does
yeah and i i you know john
if if i was insinuating anything i'm
sorry i want to make it definite i
believe you are a thief
i don't want any anything to get in the
way where you don't think that i i
honestly believe
from everything i've seen that you are a
[ __ ] criminal thief that is stolen
money
there
now you know during your lawsuit make
sure you come up with all the discovery
you know the paper trail
the names of the people involved
where the money went how much money it
was the assessment and accounting of
what was yours
in your account and what went to them
and how that was determined and so all
that [ __ ] by the way it's just for you
because like i said i won't show up i
just won't be there sue me for anything
sue me for anything
stuttering john has eight toes on each
foot there there sue me sue me he
absolutely has eight toes on each foot
go ahead oh yeah the toe litigation i am
on the toll litigation right here
so
anyway that's mostly it john's getting
uh dunked on by kumia now i got one more
clip
that is stuttering i mean everyone is
[ __ ] with him lately
this i found last night and i was
howling laughing here and this is a very
quick one and again i gotta give a shout
out to the dabblers anonymous youtube
page
which i think you guys should uh
probably subscribe to if you like all
this stuttering john buffoonery
and uh boy does john always deliver does
he not why is my camera so
wonky there we go um john always
delivers
some sweet sweet milk this is a clip of
uh
kurt metzger
i don't know what show he's on uh
could i
look i'm not gonna tell you boys over
there how to do your job
but uh at the dabblers anonymous thing
if you guys are gonna post these links
could you please or i'm sorry post these
videos could you please provide us with
at least
the name of the show or the timestamp
or at least like something to tell us
where this came from because this is
just kurt metzger on some show i don't
know these guys are
and it's not a knock on them i just
don't know who they are so i can't find
the whole full context but i thought
this would be very funny this is a kurt
metzger on some podcast
you're i mean you're in comedy right so
you still
uh i hate to use the word dabble because
i that got chrissy mayer in trouble with
okay she's going right on chrissy got in
trouble you know i know chrissy for
years she got trouble for saying dabble
she she was interviewing i think it was
the funniest thing ever like why is that
bad
she was she was it's not bad she was
interviewing um stuttering john melendez
and she's all so you still dabble in
comedy and he got all [ __ ] bent out
of shape over it he like he like
has been out of shape for him
it's got lore i i think he thought that
she didn't respect him as a comedian oh
none of us do why would we do
she's not mean it's it's funny
but like
that's that was just a very funny clip
uh
yeah none of us do
what's the problem
[Music]
but i do like the slow realization that
kurt metzger has where he dawns on him
oh sue she was just asking an innocent
question he melted down that's great